[Music]
and Asian persuasion news Oh a college
Club it submitted by love you long time
Hollis race yeah so raises I don't care
if it's races I just want them to love
me a long time or a long time right
Kentucky long time at a woman who claims
have did five thousand men wow you're
such a guy hey launch is an online
course on how to seduce rich boarders
created necessary thought it's pretty
easy to seduce which foreigners yeah
you've got to take a [ __ ] on their chest
because into that we should they love
that [ __ ]
well I'm taking notes my name is Cathy
supa dupa flip on and I'm gonna [ __ ] on
your chest you ready hey they did some
weird stuff though but I always see that
those like the the overweight balding
white male that come down from the
foreign country and they go to Asia
because they have this concept of Asian
women are submissive I'm going to give
you a couple of with time money but but
yeah a box and then I could do to
whatever I want with you
Indian women or it's dangerous you wanna
[ __ ] kill you she slept with 5,000
none that's no you dated oh okay so it
says what are her tips though rule
number one put out put out put out put
out is receipt is dated five thousand
men how old do you guys think she is
she's 25 five thousand she's in her
forties I didn't keep count that's a lot
yeah I mean if she's actually fully
seducing them that's got to be at least
like a two-week thing right I got dirty
I'll show you her photo before I tell
you her age forty five little different
good surgery whoa why is in her late 40s
late forties yeah she's a loser
no way well she looks like John Legend's
wife no a little bit early 50s you kind
of know that a little bit I think mid
40s mid 40s mid fifties early fifties
are late for you really
she was like 30-something rocket she's
82 hahahaha she might have loved me
party something I don't know 30 I see
she's uh 37 okay
she's 24 I was corrected 25 5 stump I
said I said I wanted this why does she
look like an old hag yeah she loves from
all she looks old all the older she
drained home I did yeah she trained on
this business no no not like not like no
that's what I'm telling you right now is
it I remember I said this porn stars age
really fast why dick to the big pop one
year two year for your Bob
oh no you cannot these yeah so her name
is pry yeah foodie yeah or aka Mariah or
madam Mart right oh she's not my goddamn
but she has this Facebook page where she
gives to to these girls which I don't
know cuz it's on high when she started
dating oh that's wrong when did she
starts the Jewish state a team oh that
is a good question I don't know exactly
how old she was but I do know that she
ended up living in Europe for a time and
that's how she was able to learn how to
seduce she wouldn't be able to seduce me
but her target is foreign white people
it's rich foreigners whether they're
Middle Eastern or white so it's so she's
not the targeting other Asians yeah
surely not only her magic would work
under the asian it'd be like man and if
you cheat a little too dark for Asians
that's what if you speak like a
stereotypical view oh no wonder because
like so in Thailand they have like the
type of Thai hookers that the Japanese
and Chinese and Korean businessmen want
and then they have the type of Thai
hookers that like Australians and
Europeans and Americans want yeah and
they're like different they look
different to the tastes are different so
like the East Asians they want the
hookers that are like yeah super pale
skin and all that stuff and then I feel
like the white countries they don't
really care they could they don't care
about more jungly the better
what's the legal age in in Thailand
actually prostitution is not legal it's
not we going on it's not legal but they
just just runs rampant there you know I
guess the age of consent is 1500 but um
if you are over 18 you have sex with a
minor
that's not good so it's the same
lotusphere yeah yeah what are the
sixteen right it's name is different oh
really
most eight maken Madame Raya is offering
training courses to teach other women
how to become sugar babies and so for
her VIP program she's charging a
one-time fee of fourteen thousand baht
or about four hundred and twelve US
dollars wow that's a lot yeah I use a
Hudler - yeah they get to be members of
her exclusive club and they'll receive
detailed coaching on how to seduce rich
men and how to ask them for money and
how to be more confident in bed do that
smart aleck like that really is oh well
there's also more included so I take a
[ __ ] out of buckets German CEO uh I
wonder if there's like a look
requirement though like if you if you're
not physically attractive and she sees
you guys can't help you honey selective
of who enters her via at least she's not
a fraud because she sees right here she
goes listen ugly you tried everything I
agree she talks more about people that
are just like oh let's see what this is
about I'm going to I'm going to pay for
it I'm not really in traditions like no
you have to be like in it to really what
he's looking for like call girls or
escorts that are trying to upgrade
themselves or like to find their partner
so dissociate out so the VIP plan is a
guaranteed date with a rich foreigner in
just one to three days after signing up
and one of dates with other men until
you find the partner of your dreams 100%
guarantee strategies for making money a
special strategy to ask your date for
money and then she says I get your hands
on 100,000 baht or $3,000 to 300,000
baht or $9,000 just for shopping a
course on how to negotiate payment
either before going on a date or holiday
with
rich guy or on a monthly basis and it
also includes negotiating tactics for
expensive present like a car or a condo
Wow
she also teaches them how to say
sentences in Arabic or in English to
make it easier to ask for money
whoa Jody they get to the treasure condo
buy yeah you know what I know the name
of her [ __ ] program [ __ ] power
exactly what it is it's using the power
of the [ __ ] not smart yeah honestly you
guys I feel like I don't know that
that's actually a really hard job over
there you have to do it like think about
like having to be a certain way it to
please a person for like 24/7 you
technically getting hired to act all
your life that is really gonna marry
that person yeah and you have to act in
that life as well that's ridiculous I
think they deserve the money they should
win an Oscar Award they're better actors
an actual actor seriously no but what's
funny is like I feel like there's a man
version of that like you know have you
guys heard of real social dynamics or RS
you know whatever they like backlash a
couple years back on the internet for
like them they pretty much teach this
but how to pick up women but technically
men get the stupidest end of it like we
have the stupidest things on our mind
these guys are smart they're anything
like okay how do we get money how do we
have like set of living for the real
social dynamics is how to get [ __ ]
pretty much are you got one 9sx pretty
much pretty much that's true because
guys like they're so [ __ ]
simple-minded
they don't care about how is she taking
care of me how to get a sugar mama how
how can she upgrade my life it's just I
want how to get laid and it's like it's
like a [ __ ] monkey how do I get [ __ ]
another guy makes it easier for me sugar
babies exactly I can give you that
beautiful thing about how do I get a
condo how do I get a job how do I get on
my damn dime I came back I don't know
are you smarter you know what so you see
I think when I was younger or maybe like
earlier in Jay King news I think I
probably said something louse up like I
don't think I could ever have a woman
just like support me wonder stems long
hope you've aged I've aged that I could
acted that's when you know you're a real
man yeah
is when you can have a woman take care
of you yeah what doesn't saying it's in
the beginning yeah yep [ __ ] converted
me man like I don't think that's a
problem I could provide happiness and
joy for this woman for the rest of her
life and provide that uh-huh and that
she provides me with a Ferrari do it
well if all I had to do a little review
super-deep if I could provide love and
happiness and if she could pay me back
in return
yeah what's the problem no problem exact
just wonder [ __ ] model right now and
all I had to be is a [ __ ] physical
God and like just a man like riding on a
horse butt ass naked picking her ass up
and [ __ ] mercy means you get a bomb-ass
body for it though she's like there's a
lot of pressures on that and I'm happy
because right now I like being Fitness
times so what's he know but we got to
switch this scenario out though it's not
just it's the 50 year old woman with
saggy titties oh yeah yep I'm not that
desperate okay you did your I think if
it's with the girlfriend that I'm with
right now oh I have no judgment in a lot
of guys out there that's like nope she
can't make more Tinley uh-uh and I'm
like that's a team I'm not that
competitive this that's I'm not that
competitive making a hundred million and
I'm secure with your masculinity that's
right all I got to do I could play all
[ __ ] day dude because then it'll be
the same [ __ ] for me only time nothing's
no night whoever is my partner you gotta
work let's play everything is like just
it when you want to you want to [ __ ]
do it all day make your body [ __ ] hot
do it I don't care
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode if you haven't already make sure
to hit that subscribe button because we
upload videos every single day for you
guys now to watch more videos check them
out up here
[Music]